[Musique]
et la Journée nationale des peuples
autochtones bonjour Cauet merci de vous
joindre à nous aujourd'hui pour la
souligner nous allons au cours de cette
émission parler du logement le logement
qui est un enjeu crucial pour les
Premières nations les Inuits donc les
communautés autochtones à travers le
pays
vous savez on est au Québec la crise du
logement Séville également ici et on le
ressent beaucoup avec le premier juillet
qui approche et la période des
déménagement mais sans vouloir en fait
amenuiser la difficile réalité pour bien
des gens pour bien des Québécois il y en
a une réalité qui sévit depuis très
longtemps dans les communautés
autochtones le logement on en parle on
en reparle et on ne cesse d'en parler et
pourtant les progrès n'avancent pas très
rapidement donc on va essayer de
comprendre pourquoi avec mes deux
invités donc deux invités que je joins à
Wendake et à Québec bonjour à tous les
deux c'est vous et vos enfants
chose alors Guy la touche bonjour vous
êtes
urbaniste de formation je le précise
tout de suite vous êtes le conseiller en
logement il infrastructure pour
l'Assemblée des Premières nations Québec
labrador la pnql vous y êtes depuis 36
ans n'est-ce pas
merci donc ouais vous connaissez la
réalité ça va être très intéressant de
vous entendre et d'ailleurs vous
travaillez sous l'autorité du chef de
kebab firs
donc c'est lui qui est le chef
responsable du dossier de logement et de
l'infrastructure à la pnql n'est-ce pas
le directeur général de la Société
immobilière du regroupement des centres
d'amitié autochtones du Québec la
circaque et vous vous êtes membre de la
communauté à nishnabe de kittiganzibi et
je le précise vous avez travaillé
pendant plusieurs années à la soca donc
la soccase et la société de crédit
commercial autochtone alors merci de
vous joindre à nous aussi rapidement la
circaque c'est nouveau n'est-ce pas
en 2019 et qui a omission de développer
de concevoir de construire des projets
immobiliers
alors merci à tous les deux de vous
joindre à nous également nous allons
illustrer les conditions de logement des
autochtones avec des capsules que nous
avons tourné à Joliette on va rencontrer
Jennifer Brazeau elle est la directrice
générale du Centre d'amitié autochtones
de Lanaudière on va rencontrer Luc par
la Vecchio c'est le directeur clinique
de l'intervention et de l'éducation au
même centre d'amitié au top tonnes et
puis
nous avons fait une visite dans un
logement nous sommes allés chez Laura
Dubé elle est membre de la communauté
Atika mec de Manouane c'est une
résidence de Joliette depuis plusieurs
années et là je tiens à préciser que la
réalité que vit l'aura elle n'est pas
unique à la Ville de Joliette elle n'est
pas unique aux Atika mecs en fait cette
réalité là elle s'est vie partout au
pays partout au Canada chez les
Premières nations et chez les Inuits
un petit détail tout de suite pour
commencer parce que pour bien comprendre
la réalité faut savoir que les données
les plus récentes de Statistiques Canada
nous révèle qu'en 2021 les autochtones
étaient près de deux fois plus
susceptibles de vivre dans un logement
surpeuplé donc deux fois plus que les
nonotochtones il y a un léger point
positif à cette statistique il semble
que c'est écart là ce soit légèrement
soit légèrement diminué en fait ce soir
rétrécif depuis les dernières données de
Statistiques Canada en 2016 donc c'est
une petite bonne nouvelle donc
aujourd'hui nous nous penchons sur la
situation au Québec plus
particulièrement chez les Premières
nations et nous allons commencer par
exposer la réalité alors je vous propose
tout de suite d'aller voir dans quelles
conditions vit lati Kamek Laura Dubé à
Joliette
Laura vous vivez à combien ici vous êtes
combien de personnes
cette personne donc c'est vous et vos
enfants alors 6 enfants pour combien de
pièces j'ai trois chambres puis un salon
si c'est le salon
qui était transformé en chambre
mais vous avez combien d'enfants en tout
j'ai
enfin
donc ils ne lâche pas tous ici
où sont les autres ben ils vivent dans
un autre appartement pas loin de style
son plaisir là-dedans ils vivent avec
son père comment on s'organise dans la
maison pour vivre moi je me réveille tôt
le matin en mettant 5 heures du matin
puis après ça aussi qui prennent leur
douche
et le soir alors quand on a envie de
veiller au salon on fait quoi on a dû
mettre la clé dans chacun dans leur
chambre
chacun son espace
je m'en vais dormir chez ma cousine
parce que j'ai un autre fille qui
cherche un logement puis trouve pas
encore et des fois ils sont bien couché
dans mon lit
je laisse la place alors voilà ça c'est
la réalité de Laura Dubé qui vit donc à
Joliette parce qu'en milieu urbain se
loger ce n'est pas évident pas plus que
dans les communautés on pourrait
commencer avec cet exemple là puisqu'on
était à Joliette
à quel point les besoins sont grands
monsieur hoggic à quel point c'est
difficile de se loger en milieu urbain
pour pour les autochtones
c'est une problématique qui vécue par de
nombreuses familles en milieu urbain
malheureusement
la crise le chemin n'est plus ce qui
était avant était consenti dans les
grands centres aujourd'hui
malheureusement les répandues partout au
Québec donc
[Musique]
il est présentement surpreneurs de
nombreuses années sauf que monter et
puis les membres de formation cherchent
à vouloir
et à quitter la communauté pour aller à
essayer de se trouver le meilleur
meilleur logement la meilleure urbain et
malheureusement font face à la crise de
juin ce qui ce
des familles dans des logements plus
restreints
on le voit malheureusement
économiques donc c'est un enjeu qui est
présent et que qu'on doit faire face et
que la Société immobilière du mouvement
des centaines du Québec on essaie de
pallier à cette crise là avec nos
nombreux projets vous allez nous
l'expliquer un petit peu plus tard
d'ailleurs on va développer ses projets
là Monsieur la touche décrivez-nous de
votre côté la situation actuelle du
logement dans les communautés des
Premières Nations au Québec celles que
vous connaissez bien
merci pour tout pour cet accueil
premièrement je dirais que c'est une
réalité qui est bien documentée le pnql
tient une base de données depuis l'année
2000 puis cette base de données là
révèle que la crise du logement dans les
communautés des Premières Nations au
Québec c'est quelque chose qui est bien
réel
je vais vous donner deux chiffres
retenez qu'il y a présentement 15000
unités de logements dans les 40
communautés au Québec donc 15000 unités
existantes il faudrait en ajouter 10 000
en 5 ans pour rétablir la situation
c'est quoi la situation mais c'est sur
peuplement c'est la croissance
démographique sur cinq ans puis aussi
pour permettre la migration des membres
des Premières nations qui vivent à
l'extérieur de leur communauté et qui
sont intéressés ou potentiellement
intéressés à demeurer dans leur
communauté d'appartenance vous regardez
les statistiques le taux moyen
d'occupation des maisons dans la
population québécoise se situe en deux
et deux points 5 chez les premières chez
les Premières nations
on a des taux qui se situe entre 6 et 8
personnes par logement imaginez-vous
c'est une moyenne ça signifie que
certaines maisons sont grandement sur
occupées on a eu l'exemple de Madame
Dubé tout à l'heure c'est un exemple en
communauté qui nous dit que cette
situation-là est pour justement
représentative de ce qu'on voit souvent
que l'autochtone améliore bien et est
une personne que son Conseil de banque
n'est pas en mesure de servir étant
donné les lacunes comme financement des
programmes fédéraux vous êtes je disais
au début de l'émission vous êtes là
depuis 36 ans en 1996 il y a moins de 36
ans il y a eu la Commission royale sur
les peuples autochtones et à ce
moment-là on a souligné les problèmes de
logements auxquels ils étaient déjà
confrontés la situation depuis elle
s'est améliorée ou elle s'est détériorée
je vous dirais
on relève de 34 années en arrière il y a
eu des progrès ça c'est certain je vous
dirais que par contre les besoins sont
allés en augmentation ça dépend dans
l'angle sur laquelle on le prend sont le
prince de façon strictement statistique
je vous dirais que les besoins sont plus
grands qu'il était en 1996 par contre il
y a des faux quand même me reconnaître
que des progrès il y a plus de prise en
charge locale les capacités locales sont
en développement il y a un virage qui se
fait tranquillement mais sûrement vers
l'accès la propriété individuelle il y a
beaucoup de chemin à faire encore de ce
côté-là mais notons que les besoins vont
grandement augmenter mais dans les
améliorations croisées aussi qu'on a
réussi à sensibiliser les interlocuteurs
gouvernementaux
a déployé plus de fonds pour le logement
des Premières nations voilà alors
je le disais le ras du B n'est pas la
seule à vivre dans les conditions qu'on
a montré un petit peu plus tôt ils sont
plusieurs comme ça partout à travers le
Canada je vous invite à écouter lu que
par la Vecchio c'est le directeur
clinique au calme donc dont je parlais
un petit peu plus tôt il nous explique
en fait ce à quoi les autochtones sont
face quand ils arrivent en ville on
l'écoute
quand il quitte par exemple manuel pour
venir s'installer à Joliette c'est qu'il
y a très peu de logements disponibles
qui sont quand même relativement cher
par rapport aux moyens financiers dont
ils disposent donc ça c'est une première
une première chose qu'on a souvent des
gens est-ce que vous pouvez nous trouver
ou nous aider à trouver des logements et
déjà le marché en lui-même n'est pas
favorable à trouver des des locations ça
c'est le premier le premier problème le
deuxième problème qui vont rencontrer
c'est en lien avec avec le racisme donc
on veut pas forcément louer à des
personnes autochtones donc les personnes
des caissent présentes ah ben non
finalement on a déjà loué ou donc il y a
des portes qui se ferment le troisième
c'est vraiment d'avoir des logements
aussi qui sont adaptés à
la taille des familles donc on peut se
retrouver à voir 7-8 personnes dans des
trois et demi donc il y a une
surpopulation dans l'appartement les
gens dorment tous au même endroit dans
le salon il peut y avoir trois quatre
personnes avec des tapis des tapis au
sol pour pouvoir dormir
alors parlons de ce qui a mené à la
détérioration des conditions de logement
pour les autochtones en communauté
d'abord Monsieur Latouche et il y a un
aspect historique à tout ça on remonte à
loin on remonte au moment de la
sédentarisation obligée des autochtones
tout à fait il y a des causes
historiques culturelles démographiques
historique m'avait le premier contact
les Premières nations ont dû évoluer
dans un contexte avec laquelle il était
pas nécessairement familiale et ont dû
s'adapter à des modèles qui étaient pas
les leurs et
culturellement ne correspondait pas
nécessairement à leur valeur avec
certaines même des causes des résultats
où on en est arrivé aujourd'hui il y en
a d'autres tantôt j'ai ce qui s'est un
petit peu de questions des taux
d'occupation prenez la démographie les
Premières nations c'est une population
qui est en forte croissance je voudrais
que ça peut près deux fois supérieur à
celle du Québec entre recensement si
vous voulez c'est une population très
jeune et on sait que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui c'est eux qui vont se sont
eux qui vont former des ménages des
nouvelles familles demain bon un tel
portrait ça nous laisse présager que
comme ce fut le cas dans le passé la
demande va être soutenue donc très
grande difficulté à rencontrer cette
demande le financement est un autre
facteur certainement parce que les
communautés sont sous-financées par les
programmes fédéraux on estime que ces
programmes-là répondent à peu près à 20
% des besoins des communautés dans le
domaine du logement donc
construction sont en augmentation
on voit aussi des choses comme le budget
de logements social de la CHL qui est en
diminution marquée au Québec donc tout
de suite nous mène
un portrait tel que je voulais dépeindre
en début de
sédentarisation donc au début on a créé
les communautés on les a obligés à
s'installer là éventuellement les
Premières nations les Inuits les métiers
sont eu envie de bouger de sortir et se
sont installés en ville et là aussi il y
a eu un problème de plus en plus
important surtout qu'on sait que
maintenant c'est quoi un peu plus de 50%
des Autochtones qui vivent en milieu
urbain c'est énorme ça monsieur donc
vous les voyez ils arrivent et ils sont
un peu démunis j'imagine quand ils
arrivent dans une petite moyenne ou
grande ville
obstacles pour l'accès logement
abordable et adapté à leurs besoins
parmi les obstacles ça peut être les
préjugés les préjugés des propriétaires
d'immeubles tu fais justement ton nom de
famille et famille malheureusement qui
sont dans le bas de la liste assez
rapidement il peut y avoir la Doria
linguistique la langue maternelle peut
amener
le propriétaire du meuble pour aller
chercher le logement
ensuite dans certains cas il s'agit
d'une première demande de logement pour
le docteur donc ça peut être ça peut
être complexe pour eux il y a aussi un
facteurs crédit ça n'arrive dans
certaines occasions ce que un autochtone
n'a pas de Jean-Pierre historiquement ce
qui fait que ça il y a pas dans ses
dents de montrer ou propriétaire
normalement les propriétaires se feront
à ça pensez au suivant
donc c'est
une panoplie barrière qui est
malheureusement
sur les facteurs importants
[Musique]
malheureusement le parc immobilier
à choisir un projet qui lui serait plus
rentable afin à la fin d'année donc la
construction de condo répond la
constitution de logement
de luxe qui permettant de rendre
davantage son projet alors que
malheureusement les besoins en termes de
loyer abordable adapté de côté
et en fait il y a un point qu'on peut
aborder aussi c'est
les droits que des autochtones qui
arrivent en ville ne connaissent pas
nécessairement relié au logement et ça
ça leur cause énormément de problèmes
un autre problème
heureusement les centres d'amitié
[Musique]
sont là pour les accompagner donc je
pensais un message j'avais envie de
venir n'hésitez pas à contacter le
centre de midi on va vous accompagner la
trouver un logement
on va parler des conséquences maintenant
parce que cette croissance de la
population donc on disait elle se fait
sentir jusqu'en milieu
urbain et en fait elle apporte son lot
de défi particulièrement pour les
centres d'amitié autochtones vous venez
d'en parler et vous le disiez leur
mission c'est d'offrir donc des services
de première ligne dans la plupart des
grandes villes du Québec on va écouter
Jennifer brazo qui est la directrice
générale du stand d'amitié autochtone de
Lanaudière elle nous explique justement
de la situation qui prévaut à Joliette
avec les statistiques de Statistiques
Canada il y a environ 900 autochtones
qui vit ici dans la grande région de
Joliette on a quand même plusieurs
familles qui vivent de façon transitoire
ici dans la région justement à cause des
enjeux de logements qui sont
un sourd c'est vraiment une manque de
logement dans la population générale
mais avec les ajouts de certaines
difficultés incluantes de la
discrimination les grandes familles des
logements non adaptés ça rend que il y
en a plusieurs de nos familles qui se
trouvent sans logement et c'est dans la
région avec un évidence qui est plutôt
caché alors c'est pas des états
classiques dans la rue mais surtout du
Cap surfing mais ça peut être aussi des
familles en complexe de maison à maison
alors les conséquences on va en parler
les conséquences sociales d'un logement
inadéquat qui ont été mesurés dans de
nombreuses études et là on a constaté et
je cite de mauvaises conditions de
logements sont associées à un risque
accru de propagation de maladies
infectieuses de maladies chroniques de
blessures une mauvaise alimentation et
des troubles mentaux ça peut aller très
très loin parlons-en donc la
surpopulation elle a une incidence sur
plusieurs aspects des gens concernés
parlons de la santé physique et mentale
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on découvre
dans ces logements surpeuplés
Monsieur Latouche
quand on est en communauté on le vit
une petite parenthèse tantôt madame
brasseur parlait dans le fond
l'itinérance
de surfer de divin d'une maison à
l'autre c'est sûr
que dans les communautés on parle
souvent de l'itinérance en milieu urbain
parce que les chiffrés mais dans les
communautés elle est observée également
sous une forme un peu plus cachée
exactement de la manière dont madame
brazot le décrit
on dit souvent que le logement c'est un
déterminant de la santé moi je vais
aller plus ça c'est quand tu regardes
comment les où sont situés les Premières
nations comment elles sont organisées
sur dans le contexte d'une communauté de
Première nation le logement c'est un
déterminant de la santé de l'éducation
du développement économique du mieux
être individuel là on vient chercher ce
que vous emmener madame Yvon la question
de la santé mentale tout ça
est individuel et collectif pourquoi en
raison du rôle que joue le logement dans
une société
comme les Premières nations
étant donné le contexte qu'on connaît il
faut pas être surpris que les
statistiques indiquent des écarts
importants dans la diplomation les taux
de placements d'enfants qui sont plus
élevés une seule représentation dans les
refuges pour victimes de violence ou
autre les taux de succès plus élevé par
exemple donc tout ça c'est intervalier
d'une manière ou d'une autre au rôle du
logement et quand seront là n'est pas
bien assumé c'est-à-dire avec des
conditions de vie adéquates des espaces
suffisants et bien on a des résultats et
des conséquences comme on décrit
présentement parce qu'on imagine ne pas
avoir sa propre chambre donc ne jamais
pouvoir s'isoler toujours être en groupe
on l'a vu dans le logement de Laura Dubé
ses enfants dorment dans le salon ils
n'ont pas de chambre à eux pourtant ils
sont grands ils auraient besoin de
respirer d'avoir leur espace pour
l'éducation j'imagine qu'on revient de
l'école on n'a pas on a un petit bout de
table où s'asseoir pour étudier
difficile de se concentrer quand il y a
y a beaucoup de gens autour de soi c'est
extrêmement difficile
même chose en emploi il faut ensuite
essayer d'aller travailler mais comment
comment ça touche plus particulièrement
justement les travailleurs
Monsieur Latouche
parce que
la condition de logements détermine
nécessairement comment tu évolues dans
ton quotidien quand je parlais tantôt de
mieux être individuel et collectif
c'est un nom important la question du
logement à ce niveau-là donc quelqu'un
ne peut pas performer à son travail vous
savez dans les communautés on a des
enseignants aussi on a des
professionnels de la santé je chapeau à
eux s'ils sont dans des conditions de
logement parmi les plus déplorables
qu'on a nommé pour accomplir ce qui
réussissent à faire au quotidien parce
que ça doit pas être facile quand t'as
pas par exemple une bonne nuit de
sommeil quand t'as pas par exemple aussi
un environnement qui est propice à ton
épanouissement ou cette tranquillité
dont on a tous besoin bien sûr et vous
avez abordé le thème de l'itinérance on
le voit en ville mais vous avez raison
on le voit de plus en plus en communauté
aussi et ça c'est est-ce que c'est un
problème qui pourrait s'accentuer en
communauté
mais écoutez tantôt je vais parler de
démographie jeune dynamique
c'est sûr que si on n'adresse pas le
problème à la source et une des sources
c'est la question du manque de logement
je vois pas autrement que
de telles conséquences se produisent
puis tantôt par lettre crise du logement
il y a une crise depuis longtemps dans
les communautés on parle depuis quelques
années d'une crise du logement universel
pendant l'exemple du Québec au Québec on
est vraiment dedans vous avez raison
de parler de l'arrivée du 1er juillet
qui nous confonde davantage à cette
réalité-là mais je vous dirais que les
autres ça fait 24 ans que la situation
est documentée dans les communautés des
Premières nations ce nouveau qu'on nous
autres c'est que quand la crise
atteint son fixe si on veut et là on
pourrait dire que la crise de Première
nation se déverse dans celle du Québec
ça vient pas ça vient pas arranger les
choses alors que là on a des gens qui
doivent quitter leur communauté par
manque d'espace ils vont au milieu ou
même comme il faisait avant mais là il y
a plus nécessairement ces espaces-là
d'accueil en milieu urbain et avec
toutes les défis dont Monsieur qui a
parlé tout à l'heure
l'itinérance autant sur communautés que
leur communauté c'est loin d'être
quelque chose qui se contrôle monsieur
dit qu'on va revenir à vous dans un
instant mais d'abord on va aller à
Joliette quelques secondes rencontrer
Luc par la Vecchio
et puis on va voir ce que fait le calme
pour aider ces personnes à la recherche
d'un logement ou qui sont prises dans
une situation particulière
pour aider les familles autochtones au
niveau de leur logement on va avoir deux
on va avoir plus de règles
d'interventions le premier c'était qu'on
va essayer de les aider à trouver un
logement même si le contexte est pas
très favorable à la location mais on va
aussi par exemple avoir des ententes
avec des propriétaires en leur disant
écoute avant de si jamais il y a des
enjeux de paiement de comportement etc
avis nous avant d'entamer des procédures
judiciaires ou avant d'entamer une
éviction nous on va rencontrer on va
rentrer en contact avec ces familles là
pour pour les soutenir
alors voilà Monsieur ogix c'est
justement pour contribuer au mieux être
des Autochtones qui vivent en milieu
urbain qui a été créé je disais plutôt
en 2019 la circaque la Société
immobilière du regroupement des sociétés
des centres d'amis autochtones du Québec
dont vous êtes le directeur général
et vous avez des projets vous avez
plusieurs projets en plan par les
moisissants un premier d'ailleurs qui va
toucher n'ont pas les familles en
général mais les étudiants c'est un
projet sur lequel vous êtes très très
actif en ce moment n'est-ce pas
supérieur qui avait pas objectif de
construire les lieux de vie pour
étudiants on a mis urbain certains qui
étaient choisis de porter ses projets-là
pour l'instant sur la table nous avons
quatre projets il y a le droit de
construction dont l'université on parle
32 unités
de service de première ligne permettant
là à nous qui dira de venir s'installer
avec sa famille de profiter de l'endroit
culturellement sécurisant et
des exemples de services il y a plein
d'autres devoirs des salles d'études
d'accueil des maternelles au niveau
cuisine collective
comme pour le projet Trois-Rivières
cette fois-ci on parle de 42 unités un
peu plus grandes ce qui est particulier
donc pour être vraiment à proximité pour
pouvoir offrir ces services aussi en
normandes à la fin normandes et aux
relations qui habitent à l'argent
Trois-Rivières c'est des projets
d'envergure auquel on a très hâte de
pouvoir savoir nos premières années
étudiants les deux projets à la fois ci
de Trois-Rivières on prévoit par une
rentrée progressive des étudiants dès le
mois qui sont bien il y a aussi un
projet Québec projet Québec est annoncé
auquel on travaille sur les planches
architectures si tout va bien on devrait
commencer la construction vers la fin de
l'automne qui s'en vient et vous avez vu
l'hiver projet de plus grande mercure un
peu à part de 94 unités et encore une
fois avec une période de service pour
les étudiants ce qu'on nous ce qu'on
peut l'objectif c'est de réinviter des
milieux favorable permettant à
l'étudiant d'aller chercher son diplôme
pas secondaire donc puis le quatrième
projet c'est de qui est annoncé par le
gouvernement c'est celui de notre
virgule qui devrait voir le jour lui
dans les mois de 20-25 vers 26 d'accord
donc c'est quatre projets là c'est
consacré aux étudiants on cible les
étudiants pour leur proposer un milieu
de vie agréable et inspirant pour
étudier c'est bien le cas
des
sondages il faut que ce boulot on veut
s'assurer que ce qu'on construits comme
milieu de vie bien vraiment répondre aux
besoins et que ça ressemble aussi à ce
que un étudiant là t'imagine à sa taille
comme les
faire retour aux études ou pour entamer
un nouveau projet d'études et puis on a
vu des images rouler là on était du côté
de Val d'Or avec le projet qui j'étais
est-ce que vous pouvez m'en parler ça
c'est on laisse les étudiants de côté on
parle plutôt de logements sociaux
urbain et il y a ce projet qui est en
brand du côté de Val d'Or le projet qui
jatait avez-vous des détails
j'ai pas beaucoup de détails sur le
projet de la danse que je sais par
contre c'est un projet comme
l'inventionner pour famille aller à
besoin des services sociaux
normalement les besoins qui sont
toujours exprimés donc on fait des
sondages autant auprès des étudiants que
des familles ce que ce qui est exprimé
c'est on veut beaucoup plus incroyable
on peut oui sécuritaire adapté pour nous
permettre de s'y emménager avec notre
famille qui sont normalement plus
nombreux qu'une famille à l'octobre et
on veut aussi les services des services
de première année qui permet justement
de pouvoir
mieux vivre et
pouvoir justement être amélioré nos
conditions de famille conditions de vie
etc alors c'est encourageant de voir
qu'il y a du pain sur la planche il y a
aussi du pain sur la planche du côté de
Joliette on va aller voir ce que mijote
Jessica Braso et son équipe
ici dans la région de la longueur on a
plusieurs projets de court terme moyen
terme et plus longtemps en train de
explorer et déployer on a un projet
d'infrastructure avec des logements ou
si un nouveau Centre d'amitié qui va
être construit à l'intérieur pas loin de
notre centre actuelle où est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir accueillir des membres de la
communauté de façon temporaire et moyen
terme pour pouvoir aider aussi à la
faire de la transition entre la
communauté et la ville ou pouvoir
stabiliser des individus peut-être
qu'ils sont en situation de crise ou de
soutien psychosocial on a aussi le
projet qu'on est en visionne pour le
site actuel qu'on déménage dans cette
nouvelle réforme c'est de créer des
logements
abordables pour les membres de la
communauté parce qu'on voit que quand
même un énorme besoin de logement ici
dans la région et on est en train
d'explorer aussi la possibilité de créer
de création de logements dans la région
de Saint-Michel-des-Saints
alors à l'Assemblée des Premières
Nations du Québec et Labrador Monsieur
Latouche vous ne développez pas des
projets par contre vous faites valoir
les besoins des communautés autochtones
auprès de différents organismes auprès
de services aux autochtones Canada et de
la SCHL comment ça se passe votre
rencontre comment ça se passe vos
relations avec eux
au Québec on a une situation assez
unique malgré les agendas très
différents
des parties je vous avais par exemple
comme service aux autochtones Canada est
un ministère de financement la SCHL est
vraiment un organisation business
gouvernemental et l'assemblée à Bras
d'Or avant tout l'organisation politique
c'est la table des gestes ont réussi à
bien s'entendre sur les objectifs et les
efforts à mettre en commun pour
avantager la région donc la région qu'on
a bien contexte c'est bien documenté et
on a un plan d'action dans lequel les
trois parties contribuent
régulièrement et fortement à l'atteinte
des objectifs régionaux pour une
meilleure pour une amélioration des
conditions de vie des membres de
Première nation au Québec
la question de l'argent est importante
la pnql a dénoncé le dernier budget du
gouvernement fédéral on veut investir 4
milliards de dollars je pense sur sur 7
ans ça devrait entrer en vigueur l'année
prochaine donc 2024 2025 et on disait
que c'est un financement qui doit servir
à la mise en œuvre d'une stratégie de
logement autochtone autant dans les
milieux
urbains ruraux que nordique il y en a
pas déjà une stratégie la stratégie elle
est là non comment ça se fait que on
parle toujours de nouvelles stratégies
depuis le temps il a que le problème
persiste
quand on parle de la stratégie
urbaine rurale et nordique il faut
comprendre que c'est
sa vise directement ce qu'on peut
appeler le hors communauté donc ce n'est
pas le logement des communautés le
logement des communautés ont fait
l'objet d'un annonce dans le passé
il y a une stratégie effectivement
nationale sur le logement de la SCHL et
étant donné le contexte particulier des
Premières nations et des autres
collectivités autochtones il fut d'un
commun accord décidé que ça prendra une
stratégie spécifique pour les
autochtones que ce soit sur communauté
ou hors communautés c'est pour ça qu'on
parle maintenant de la stratégie dont
vous avez des que vous avez des crites
et qui
s'intègrent la stratégie nationale sur
le logement de la SCHL d'accord mais
quand vous permettez
de dormir et budget fédéral parce que
malgré cette nouvelle annonce pour la
stratégie hors communauté il y a pas de
fonds qui ont additionnelles qui ont été
annoncés pour le logement sur réserve là
où les besoins sont également criants
sur communautés et pourtant nous on est
capable de faire la démonstration qu'à
chaque fois que le fédéral s'engage et
mets des fonds additionnels en logement
sur communauté parce que c'est un des
moyens de s'en sortir chaque dollars
investi génère 4 dollars en prêt ou en
mise de fonds de la part des conseils
des communautés ou des individus donc
investir dans le logement première
nation c'est ça amène des retombées et
n'oublions pas les autres retombées dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure le mieux être
des résultats scolaires la santé etc
alors pour les communautés vous recevez
de l'argent donc du fédéral maintenant
or communauté il y a aussi de l'argent
qui arrive de la part du gouvernement du
Québec on a annoncé 50 millions de
dollars sur trois ans et on dit que ça a
été promis là pour permettre entre
autres l'amélioration du logement dans
les communautés encore et en milieu
urbain est-ce qu'il y a une partie de
l'argent du provincial qui sert dans les
communautés autochtones au Québec qui
peut me répondre à la question monsieur
la touche oui
si vous voulez quand on parle d'un
logement sur communauté il y a pas de
fond du Québec exactement
avantage le Québec à ce que la situation
du logement s'améliore dans les
communautés quand on a parlé de
déversement mais c'est sûr que le
débordement qui se produit des
communautés vers le milieu urbain se
traduit par l'itinérance plus demande
dans le judiciaire plus de monde dans le
système pénal
c'est pas par choix que les gens font ça
c'est par la force des choses absolument
oui alors ce 50 millions du gouvernement
du Québec qui a été annoncé lors du
dernier budget est-ce que c'est ce qui
vous permet de développer vos projets
avec la société immobilière
à financer les projets auxquels qu'on
développe par contre nous ce qu'on la
problématique qu'on vit malgré que
l'argent peut être disponible en
meilleur
peu la compl
[Musique]
mais aussi avec avec des services qui
tournent les familles et puis de vivre
puis justement pour développer ses
espaces que nous parlons l'accès au
service et ça prend du financement autre
que ce qui est annoncé aussi par le
gouvernement qui constatait uniquement
sur un loyer abordable donc nous dans
nos projets ça vient
et beaucoup plus que font les 10 12 15
heures de fonds
[Musique]
d'assouplissement de ces financements
qui sont annoncés nous permettrait
justement d'avancer facilement dans la
réalisation d'un financement de nos
projets qui est vraiment répondre
oui c'est ce que nous dit aussi Jennifer
Brazeau au sein d'amitié autochtone de
Lanaudière elle aussi elle a du
financement qui vient d'un petit peu
partout on va l'écouter une dernière
fois
on a multip différents partenaires
financiers qui nous soutient à travers
ses projets là c'est quand même des
projets assez complexes justement avec
nos nouveaux projets d'infrastructure
pendant la gouverne le gouvernement du
Québec nous a donné un investissement de
trois points
on a aussi le gouvernement fédéral avec
un investissement de deux points 8
millions plus plusieurs différents
projets et partenariats avec la
ministère de la Famille
le ministère d'habitation
et municipalités alors on a quand même
un soutien accru à travers différents
ministères on est soucis à la recherche
des partenaires privés
et j'ai envie de conclure cette émission
en citant la lettre de mandat en tant
que ministre de la ministre responsable
des services aux autochtones papier adjo
soit que cette dernière en fait à
l'obligation de combler les écarts en
matière d'infrastructure d'ici 2030 en
mettant l'accent sur la construction de
logements durable et abordable alors je
vais vous poser la question à tous les
deux même si on est aussi en milieu
urbain avec Monsieur logic mais est-ce
que vous croyez est-ce que vous croyez
que c'est dans l'ordre du possible
est-ce que vous croyez que c'est dans
l'ordre du réalisable monsieur la touche
d'abord
on construit dans les communautés
première nation au Québec en moyenne 225
logements par année tantôt je parlais
d'un besoin 10000 sur 50 ça veut dire
qu'il faudra en construire deux mille et
non 225 pour sur une période de 5 ans
pour éliminer le retard bon vous me
demandez si réaliste la seule manière
que ce soit réaliste ça prend des
conditions une des conditions ce serait
un investissement fédéral
massif pour régler la crise du logement
mais à la pnql la vision c'est de parler
de partenariat à l'intérieur
[Musique]
un type de partenariats à l'intérieur
duquel tout s'assume leur porte de
responsabilité donc collectivement c'est
quelque chose qui est réalisable mais
c'est sûr que ça passe par un
investissement fédéral massif absolument
en milieu urbain monsieur est-ce que
vous pensez qu'on va finir par
résorber cette crise du logement pour
les autochtones
oui oui puis on le souhaite un certain
pour ça nous dans un monde ce qu'on
souhaiterait ça serait peut-être le
meilleur arrivage entre les maires de
fonds
de voir assouplir
le financement les contraintes qu'on
doit faire face lorsqu'on dépend de
projets des fois il y a des dates de
dépôt qui concordent pas avec la date de
dépôt de notre programme donc si on fait
ça arrivera ensemble les fonds
disponibles permettant de faire une
demande de financement pour nos projets
ça me permettrait justement de venir
essayer de répondre aux besoins clients
d'avoir participé à cette émission
d'avoir exposé le problème d'avoir
réfléchi aussi à ce qui était possible
de faire d'avoir parlé de vos projets
surtout qui sont vraiment intéressants
et importants
alors merci Guy Latouche à la pnql
Miguel Laurent odjik à la circaque et
bonne chance dans vos projets et à vous
deux et à tous une bonne et belle
journée nationale des peuples
autochtones et à la prochaine au revoir
[Musique]